bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte
écologie et santé publique
longtemps on a agi comme s'il n'y avait
aucun lien entre ces deux domaines
mais la pandémie actuelle nous montre
que la santé humaine la santé animale et
la santé des écosystèmes sont en fait
est indissociable et ce concept d'une
santé provoque de plus en plus la
collaboration des virologues et des
biologistes ce chercheur est engagé dans
une course
gary cabine guerre travaillent sur un
vaccin contre la coved 19
pathogènes virus il connaît bien la
contribuer à la découverte du vaccin qui
a stoppé le terrible virus ebola mais
chaque fois que nouveau virus apparaît
il a l'impression que l'histoire se
répète au moins tout le temps un peu le
bateau à quelque part dans ce sens que
quand président un frangin encore un
virus puis quand présents sur ces autres
choses aux prises influence en asie qui
ont un frein au mexique
[Musique]
et si on revoyait notre approche mieux
comprendre ce qui se passe avec les
animaux pour mieux prévenir la
transmission des virus à l'humain
alphonse ça serait bien plus facile de
prévenir ce sont là que de développer
des vaccins pour 8 milliards d'individus
un peu partout des chercheurs partent à
l'aventuré
ils veulent débusquer les virus à
l'origine des prochaines pandémies et le
canada est engagée dans cette chasse au
virus
mais 2020 et lauzoua près de québec nous
sommes en plein coeur de la première
vague de coved 19
c'est soir viennent des états unis où
elles ont passé l'hiver ça progresse
d'un tranchant
[Musique]
tout près de là un chercheurs tentent de
les attirer dans ses filets pierre
legagneux est un spécialiste de l'oie
blanche et ce printemps
il est aussi chasseur de virus c'est
qu'avant d'arriver ici c'est oit ont
transité par l'état de new york new york
était alors un point chaud de la
pandémie comme ses oies vont bientôt
repartir vers le nord pourrait-elle
transmettre la coved 19 aux communautés
nordiques
le chercheur doit confirmer l'absence du
coronavirus on aura une preuve
irréfutable que d'un danloy blanche n'y
a pas de sas co2 et on va communiquer
largement auprès des communautés inuites
et autochtones qui vont chasser l'oie
blanche donc dans très peu de temps on
va communiquer là dessus
moi je penses tu es bien d'aller de
poster un après des heures d'attentes
les premières joies s'approche des
filets c'est le moment de déclencher le
piège
[Musique]
sa perte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il fait presque nuit quand l'équipe
rapporte une cinquantaine doit au camp
de base
[Musique]
tout doucement on dirige les protégés
vers le laboratoire de fortune
[Musique]
pandémie oblige tout le personnel a été
testé pour la corée 19
malgré tout on ne prend aucun risque
pour les oiseaux on débute par le
prélèvement du sart skov 2 le virus de
la coved 19 pierre legagneux doute que
les oies en soit porteuse mais la
science a besoin de preuves et on ne
connaît toujours pas les espèces qui
pourraient être les réservoirs du virus
de la coved 19
on prélève ensuite une goutte de sang
cette étape est capitale en laboratoire
cet échantillon servira à dresser
l'inventaire des virus qui héberge l'oie
blanche
quand vous aurez tous terminés les oies
qu'est ce que vous faites avec ce soir
on les relâche pas tout de suite on veut
les garder ici pourquoi qu'elle soit
désorientés on va les relâcher au lever
du soleil
[Musique]
la coved 19 met en lumière l'importance
de ces chasseurs de virus
leur travail est d'autant plus important
quand on sait maintenant que les trois
quarts des maladies infectieuses
proviennent des animaux sida strass
ebola et le maire ce les virus de ces
maladies émergentes avaient comme
réservoir soit des chauves souris des
chimpanzés ou encore des oiseaux les
virus émergents seraient même en
progression
on s'attend ce que de plus en plus de
virus franchissent la barrière des
espèces on empiète de plus en plus sur
les écosystèmes et notre population
augmente sans cesse
c'est de l'eau on vient vers la basse
que les études écologiques de ce
comprend comment les pathogènes se
transmettent pourquoi quelle espèce
qu'est-ce qui fait dans leur génome qui
puisse être adapté un espace où l'eau
toutes ses connaissances
c'est là a dû abaisser de prévenir une
explosion dans la population humaine
gary coppinger donne comme exemple la
terrible épidémie d'ebola ils étaient
sur la ligne de front
quand émergent ce virus en afrique de
l'ouest en 2014 le manque de
connaissances a coûté cher en vies
humaines
aujourd'hui on comprend mieux la
transmission du virus de même que les
animaux qui le propagent des exemples
documenté d'infection cette menace il ya
des pancartes
de port avancé les animaux mais il ya
aussi d'autres espèces on a des soupçons
qui sont impliqués catégorie d'antilopes
il ya les paroles sauvages ces animaux
qualifiée de réservoir ou de vecteur à
virus semble bien loin de nous vu d'ici
détrompez vous le pays possède lui aussi
ces espèces capables de déclencher une
pandémie à l'université laval
on surveille une porte d'entrée ni connu
des virus en amérique le nord canadien
cette équipe tente de débusquer les
virus de la grippe aviaire qui menace la
santé humaine
c'est cette équipe qui analyse les
échantillons prélevés à l'île aux noix
au moment de préparer ce reportage
le directeur de cette équipe était
retenu à shanghai en chine
il organise des expéditions pour
dépister le virus de la copie de 19 chez
les chauves souris
malgré la distance
le nord canadien reste une des priorités
pour ce chercheur le canada est au coeur
des grandes routes migratoires
chaque printemps des millions d'oiseaux
remonte vers le nord pour se reproduire
en automne c'est chemin inverse
parmi ces oiseaux des sauvagines ces
oiseaux aquatiques sont les réservoirs
des virus de l'influenza aviaire à
certaines souches sont hautement
pathogène c'est le cas du h5n1 8 un
virus qui fait trembler
stéphane chéry 2014 en colombie
britannique
l'agencé canadienne d'inspection des
aliments a fait abattre par mesure
préventive
des milliers de volailles la raison une
éclosion soudaine 2 h 58
[Musique]
on a démontré que ce virus est entré par
le détroit de béring au nord des oiseaux
infectés en corée du sud ont migré vers
le nord et contaminer d'autres oiseaux
migrateurs
ceux ci sont par la suite redescendu le
long de la côte ouest infectant au
passage des fermes et des oiseaux
d'élevage
jusqu'ici le h5 n 8 n'a pas fait le saut
chez l'humain mais c'est un scénario que
redoutent l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
ces virus sont reconnus pour muter
rapidement ils ont tous un potentiel
pour déclencher la prochaine épidémie de
grippe aviaire
après nos attitudes ministre milite
aussi une chose qui est essentiel à une
réponse aux épidémies efficace c'est la
rapidité fait c'est sûr que si on est au
courant du problème
à partir du moment où on a une infection
dans le grand nord ou même avant si
possible
c'est beaucoup plus facile de répondre
que si on est rendu déjà à 10000 code en
émoi
octobre au cap tourmente près de québec
les oies sont de retour et parmi elles
celle que pierre legagneux à capturer le
chercheur a pu rassurer les communautés
nordiques au printemps les tests ont
tous confirmé l'absence du virus de
lakovic 19
reste à établir maintenant la carte des
autres virus présent chez l'oie blanche
avoir un inventaire global de ckoi la
diversité virale au sein d'organismes
comme comme l'oie des neiges qui est une
espèce quand même proche de l'humain je
pense que c'est c'est important d'avoir
cette information-là puis on va sûrement
répéter ça plusieurs fois juste pour
avoir un espèce de coeur de réseau de de
surveillance ou
avec la crise sanitaire actuelle
on se rend bien compte que la santé
humaine est indissociable de celle des
animaux et des écosystèmes
d'ailleurs des scientifiques veulent de
plus en plus rapprochées l'écologie de
la médecine ce concept qu'on appelle une
seule santé et mis de l'avant par
quelques pays dont le canada pour geri
cabine guerre
cette approche est désormais primordial
face aux maladies infectieuses le
chercheur rappelle que les virus n'ont
pas fini de nous surprendre
[Musique]
tajan qui sont prédits par des modèles
mathématiques
on en connaît son âge je suis un peu
plus mail qui cause une maladie chez
l'humain non il faut être prêt à tous
les niveaux
en